merci Julien barjoton de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure élu de Paris il manque du
groupe RDPI ce sont les sénateurs de la
majorité présidentielle et vous êtes
vice-président de la Commission des
affaires de la culture on va parler de
votre apport sur la filière musicale
française dans quelques instants mais
d'abord l'actualité c'est cette
démission du maire de Saint-Brevin hier
sa commune et le centre de tension suite
à un projet de déplacement de centre
d'accueil de demandeurs d'asile il avait
reçu des menaces son domicile personnel
avait été incendies il dénonce un manque
de soutien de l'État est-ce que cet élu
a été abandonné d'abord il faut renvoyer
la responsabilité à ceux d'extrême
droite qui ont suscité cette
ces attaques contre ce maire et moi je
voudrais l'assurer de ma solidarité
comme l'a fait le chef de l'État et
comme l'a fait également la première
ministre et l'ensemble de la classe
politique à l'exception notable de
Marine Le Pen et de son groupe qui ne se
sont pas levés dans l'hémicycle pour le
saluer je pense que c'est une mauvaise
une mauvaise réaction et ça suscite
quand même une une interrogation parce
que
derrière c'est l'extrême droite qui ne
veut pas qu'on puisse accueillir des
demandeurs d'asile alors que c'est notre
humanité qu'il exige et que ça fait
partie des règles de la République donc
ce n'est pas la République qui abandonne
ce sont les ennemis de la République qui
ont attaqué ce maire il ne faut pas
inverser les choses le préfet à livrer
un certain nombre d'explications le
maire va être reçu je crois au Sénat la
semaine prochaine il pourra expliquer ce
qu'il sait produit c'est effectivement
extrêmement grave le gouvernement
propose de renforcer la protection des
mers je note que nous avions voté une
loi en 2019 qui renforçait la protection
juridique des des maires et puis leur
possibilité d'agir l'information etc
sont impulsion de Sébastien Lecornu donc
il faut sans doute continuer dans son
sens cette bande dit qu'il faut mieux
protéger les élus encore est-ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin est-ce qu'il faut
d'autres mesures oui il faut sans doute
d'autres mesures mais vous savez il faut
d'abord que nous retrouvions le sens
commun c'est à dire ce qui fait le sel
de la République c'est la fraternité on
va pas se dire que on peut accepter
qu'en France des mouvements d'extrême
droite par la pression par les menaces
et par le passage à l'acte poussent à la
démission des mers c'est d'abord ça
qu'il faut dénoncer c'est d'abord ça
qu'il faut retrouver parce que sinon ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on met
des patrouilles de gendarmes devant tous
les mers qui sont susceptibles d'être
attaqués je crois que nous avons besoin
de retrouver d'abord la fermeté
l'autorité de la République et donc
c'est bien que tous les élus se
rassemblent ensuite s'il y a des mesures
supplémentaires pour pouvoir protéger
les mers lorsqu'ils ont des décisions
difficiles à accompagner il faut sans
doute le faire mais avec ce maire il a
l'air si liberté pendant des semaines
sur le fait qu'il était victime de
menaces son domicile a été incendié il y
a plusieurs semaines pourquoi il n'a pas
été mieux protégé à ce qu'il n'a pas
raison de dénoncer un abandon de l'État
je pense que il y a effectivement assez
la situation est extrêmement choquante
le préfet a expliqué qu'un certain
nombre de mesures avaient quand même été
prises donc l'alerte avait été entendu
les appels avaient été reçus on constate
que malheureusement ça n'a pas permis
d'empêcher ce passage à l'acte mais la
responsabilité de ce passage à l'acte
c'est pas celle de l'État c'est pas
celle du président de la République que
ça ce sont ces factieux d'extrême droite
qui sont dangereux pour la République on
va continuer à parler de ce sujet c'est
aussi l'actualité dans nos régions avec
nos partenaires de la presse régionale
on va à Limoges où on retrouve
Anne-Sophie PDR bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nos rédactrices en chef
adjointe aux populaires du centre et
avec vous Anne-Sophie justement on
revient sur cette émission d'élus
oui bonjour Oriane bonjour monsieur le
sénateur
cette démission d'élus effectivement
elle est marquante et tout le monde en
parle mais sur nos territoires
ruraux en Haute-Vienne en Corrèze ou en
Creuse c'est quelque chose qui est qui
est presque quotidien
nos confrères de la montagne en Creuse
ont fait état de 14 démissions depuis
deux ans de mère
sur le territoire
c'est c'est très inquiétant pour nous ça
montre que vous parliez tout à l'heure
de l'extrême droite mais c'est pas le
seul problème sur nos territoires c'est
aussi une incompatibilité entre le
travail de mère puisque c'est un travail
à plein temps avec des charges qui sont
très lourdes et parfois la vie
professionnelle est personnelle à côté
puisque la plupart des maires de nos
campagnes travaillent à côté et ils ont
extrêmement ils ont beaucoup de mal à
faire à faire le joint est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas là aussi peut-être mieux
les former mieux les accompagner vous en
parliez tout à l'heure et être peut-être
plus proche d'eux sur le terrain
les élus dans les petites communes ont
besoin de moyens donc en effet il faut
faire le bilan de cette loi de 2019
trois ans après et puis voir comment la
compléter et l'améliorer parce que et
bien les maires sont les piliers de la
République parce que c'est la République
elle s'exprime d'abord dans les maires
c'est la maison commune du peuple la
blog quand on est un citoyen français et
que on s'adresse qu'on veut voir en
quelque sorte les personnes qui
représentent la République c'est le
maire c'est là où on fait ses démarches
c'est là où on peut poser des questions
sur sa vie quotidienne etc donc en effet
faisons le point sur ce qui a fonctionné
dans la loi 2019 et ce qu'il faut encore
compléter parce que il y a une
difficulté de l'engagement mais ça
touche aussi peut-être l'ensemble de la
société il y a le sujet des maires il y
a le sujet aussi de l'engagement
associatif de l'engagement militant de
l'engagement syndical nous vivons dans
un monde où cet engagement est plus
compliqué ça nécessiterait que tout
finalement tous les représentants qui
soient syndicaux politiques ou autres
puissent interroger sur le sens de
l'engagement aujourd'hui dans une
société plus complexe et plus dure et la
façon de d'améliorer leur situation
et lorsque ça dérape comme un coma
Brévin il est sans doute aussi
nécessaire d'aller plus loin parce que
vous le disiez tout à l'heure il y a une
audition il y a il y a deux ans
destinateurs mais aujourd'hui il a que
21% des plantes qui qui aboutissent à
une condamnation il faut là aussi sans
doute aller plus loin oui ça faisait
partie effectivement tout le sujet de la
protection fonctionnait les juridique
faisait partie de la loi que porter
Sébastien Lecornu en 2019 et
effectivement ça fait partie du bilan
qu'il faut qu'il faut en faire et voir
s'il faut davantage renforcer les
sanctions qu'il y avait déjà été
renforcées vous souvenez suite au décès
de ce maire dans le Var parce qu'il
s'était opposé à une décharge sauvage et
donc on avait déjà renforcé les
sanctions lorsque on s'en prenait à un
élu de la République il faut voir
comment les peines ont été appliquées
combien de plaintes ont été déposés et
s'il faut davantage encore les
sanctionner par rapport déjà ces trois
croissements qui avaient eu lieu
pourquoi pas ça ce sera l'objet je pense
d'un débat notamment au Sénat qui est le
la chambre qui représente les
collectivités
comme tous les vendredis dossier sur les
mobilités
oui voilà dans le populaire du centre
nous avons choisi depuis quelques
semaines de
nous pencher sur la mobilité nos
territoires
creuse Corrèze Haute-Vienne sont mal
desservies que ce soit par le train par
l'avion par la route où on s'est
extrêmement compliqué pour les gens de
se déplacer donc on a choisi donc avec
nos deux journalistes Guillaume
Bellavoine et Jean-Louis Mercier de
s'attaquer à trouver sur le terrain des
alors pas que des choses qui marchent
pas justement on va essayer de proposer
des solutions là toutes ces prochaines
semaines sur les des solutions de
mobilité alors aujourd'hui ce vendredi
nous proposons nous ont un zoom sur un
garage solidaire qui est à Limoges qui a
ouvert il y a un an et qui propose au
chômeurs
et aux gens en recherche d'emploi de
pouvoir venir réparer leur voiture à
moindre coût et même quand ils n'en ont
pas de pouvoir les réparer ou louer des
scooters ou des voitures pour pouvoir
accéder à l'emploi que ce soit oui à
l'emploi ou à la formation voilà des
exemples comme celui-ci on en a on en a
plein que ce soit sur sur on va essayer
de traiter les démarches sont
environnementales les mobilités douces
voilà des solutions pour que tout le
monde puisse voir sur le territoire
comment il peut se déplacer en dehors de
ce qui existe et c'est à l'air dans le
populaire du centre merci beaucoup merci
Anne-Sophie d'avoir été avec nous
réparer à petit prix c'est à la Une de
votre journal aujourd'hui merci d'avoir
été avec nous on va continuer sur le
reste de l'actualité Julien barjoton
Emmanuel Macron qui a donc présenté sa
grande ses grandes lignes de la
stratégie réindulte réalisation hier et
notamment son projet pour l'industrie
verte avec une phrase qui a fait réagir
y compris dans votre camp Emmanuel
Macron qui demande une pause dans la
réglementation environnementale
européenne il dit qu'il y a déjà assez
de normes mais et que il faut faire
attention sur la concurrence par rapport
à de l'Union européenne est-ce que vous
approuvez cette phrase cette pause si le
président de la République présente un
plan pour industrie verte avec un projet
de loi qui arrive d'abord au Sénat c'est
bien pour aller plus loin sur la
transition écologique de notre industrie
c'est un plan extrêmement important
qu'il a proposé notamment il y aura un
crédit d'impôt industriel pour faire
levier et pour avoir plus de projets
industriels qui souvent favorables à la
transition écologique également sur les
territoires d'industrie ou encore sur un
certain nombre de mesures de subventions
qu'il a annoncé ce qu'il veut dire c'est
que la concurrence au niveau mondial
elle doit être aussi loyale et sincère
donc il faut pas faire preuve de naïveté
il faut d'abord appliquer les textes qui
existent et surtout aller exactement ce
qu'il a dit aller plus loin dans le
financement c'est-à-dire à la fois par
les impôts en les baissant et par les
subventions et d'ailleurs parfois je
note que ici au 7 mars on a des débats
sur la complexité des normes notamment
environnementales mais pas seulement
donc il ne s'agit pas d'empiler les
normes il s'agit d'être efficace et de
rattraper les États-Unis et de ne pas se
laisser avoir par la Chine sur ces
sujets c'est tout simplement le bon sens
le chef de l'État qui va continuer à
parler réindustrialisation il sera
Dunkerque aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il
y a une volonté de sa part d'avancer
dans le quinquennat et de tourner la
page des retraites sauf qu'il y a une
nouvelle échéance et le 8 juin
l'Assemblée nationale qui va examiner la
proposition de la liotte pour abroger la
réforme vous êtes inquiète son adoption
je trouve ça très choquant d'abord c'est
un détournement de procédure si on
commence à déposer des propositions de
loi pour supprimer des projets de loi
qui vient d'être adoptés je veux dire on
peut aller loin comme ça on va s'amuser
franchement ça n'est pas à la hauteur ça
n'est pas le rôle d'une proposition de
loi que de venir abroger un texte
immédiatement adopté deuxièmement
surtout qu'il a été promulgué il y a un
mois maintenant deuxièmement personne
n'a voté l'iode le groupe lot c'est un
groupe tampon qui finalement s'arroche
le droit de faire la pluie et le beau
temps alors que les Français ils avaient
le choix entre
la majorité précédentielle les LR etc il
se trouve que des députés éparpillés se
retrouvent dans un groupe et on fait
quoi comme sous la Quatrième République
un groupe tampon qui peut faire changer
les majorités c'est pas ça la démocratie
la démocratie la démocratie
la démo ça c'est sinon ça c'est un
plaidoyer contre la proportionnelle ou
contre la démocratie ce genre de choses
c'est pas un groupe on se retrouve comme
dans des pays où des minuscules groupes
font chuter les gouvernements etc les
Français ils veulent des choix un
exécutif qui les porte et qui les
appliquent voilà donc on peut continuer
je comprends qu'il y a des gens qui
soient pas d'accord mais moi je trouve
cette proposition extrêmement
extrêmement choquante elle elle n'est
pas dans les traditions et les règles
d'un débat sincère apaisé vous voyez ça
fait partie ce genre de choses qui
hystérise le débat il y a des règles
particulières un pour une niche
parlementaire à minuit quelle que soit
l'état du texte la discussion s'arrête
est-ce que la majorité présidentielle va
faire durer les débats pour que le vote
n'est pas lieu alors moi j'ai pas un
prononcé sur le choix du groupe je suis
au Sénat c'est pas comme prononcer sur
le choix des groupes de la majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale on aimerait pas
l'inverse
moi je pense voilà qu'on n'est pas qu'on
n'est pas toujours obligé d'être naïf
ils le font alors en même temps on se
prévoit pas des turpitudes des autres il
faut aussi être parfois responsable pour
deux voilà moi vraiment je regrette
qu'un groupe qui n'existait pas dans au
moment du débat démocratique des
législatives et qui n'est juste un
groupe tampon essaye comme ça de mettre
une pression invraisemblable sur un
texte dont nous savons qu'il est
contesté mais qui a été adopté et
notamment au Sénat et qui est désormais
promulguée
ECAL française de son financement vous
avez remis un rapport à ce sujet on va
revoir les détails avec notre
journaliste parlementaire Quentin calmé
[Musique]
bonjour Quentin bonjour Oriane bonjour
Julien barjoton bonjour
Quentin ce rapport a donc été remis au
mois d'avril à la ministre de la Culture
il plaide en faveur d'une stratégie
offensive à portée pour la filière
musicale française exactement l'idée
avancée aussi par le chef de l'État et
rappeler dans votre rapport Julien bar
jeton c'est et bien de placer la France
en tête de la production des contenus
culturels et créatifs c'est l'objectif
d'ailleurs qui avait formulé Emmanuel
Macron lors de la présentation
souvenez-vous de son plan pour la France
en 2030 c'était un plan annoncé en
octobre 2021 dans votre rapport Julien
barjoton vous fixez trois lignes
d'action pour arriver à faire de la
France ce fleuron de la culture dans le
monde déjà et bien l'export et le
développement international des
créations françaises l'innovation le
numérique et la structuration du tissu
économique français pour garantir que
les centres de décision restent en
France et par là assurer notre
souveraineté culturelle vous dites que
le Nouveau Centre national de la musique
créé en 2019 et le bon acteur pour
mettre en place la stratégie et vous
plaidez dans votre rapport c'est un peu
la mesure que Ton a retenu en faveur
d'une nouvelle contribution sur le
streaming le streaming pour ceux qui ne
sont pas à la page c'est cette musique
en flux sur Internet porté par des
plateformes comme le français Deezer ou
encore le Suédois Spotify car c'est le
secteur le plus porteur vous le dites de
la création 61% des revenus en 2021
également celui qui est le plus en
hausse dans ses revenus et dont vous
parlez de créer une taxe de
1,75% sur les revenus du streaming
musical alors cette proposition elle
divise monsieur ben jetons la lu dans le
journal Le Monde on voit que et bien les
plateformes bien sûr et certain
producteurs de musique se disent déçus
de votre proposition et en plus votre
proposition elle ignorerait les gars
femme c'est géants du numérique ou aussi
des réseaux sociaux qui sont en forte
progression comme Tic-Toc c'est ce que
raconte le journal jouait à faire non de
la tête
nous déjà un peu voilà quel était votre
idée avec votre rapport est-ce que c'est
bien résumé c'est très bien résumé je
vous remercie de l'avoir présenté ainsi
parce que c'est vraiment l'esprit on
s'est rendu compte que la musique avait
besoin d'une stratégie comme l'avait
d'ailleurs dit le président de la
République pour les industries
culturelles comme il y en a il y a un
Centre national du livre et il y a un
Centre national du cinéma
de la musique et lui est très récent
2000 fin 2019 début 2020 et donc des
années 40 le ministère de la Culture
donc la musique a besoin d'une stratégie
vers l'export puisque nous perdons des
places ça progresse mais nous perdons
des places nous sommes désormais en 6e
peut-être bientôt rattrapé par la Corée
du Sud qui est très offensive avec la
K-pop le le choc du numérique qui
bouleverse cette économie notamment avec
l'intelligence artificielle pour créer
des musiques de films par exemple mais
aussi bien sur la blockchain ou les NFT
et puis également l'écosystème vous
l'avez rappelé le fait qu'il faut avoir
des majors mais aussi des gros
indépendants et des petites entreprises
et donc l'idée c'est vraiment d'impulser
une stratégie volont en faveur de la
musique la contribution elle vient
permettre de financer cette stratégie et
elle s'applique et évidemment aux
plateformes gratuites vous dites que ça
divise il y a une très large adhésion
qu'ils disent c'est normal le monde il y
a une très large adhésion il y a 14
organisations professionnelles qui ont
signé une motion pour dire qui soutenait
le rapport et ses conclusions c'est
inédit c'est inouï c'est la première
fois que les tous les acteurs du
spectacle vivant les indépendants les
producteurs indépendants sont ensemble
pour signer un texte en effet les majors
si opposent mais en réalité c'est
seulement les majors et je note que
leur siège n'est pas en France ce sont
c'est une spécificité de la musique
c'est que contrairement aux livres et
aux disques les trois principales majors
n'ont pas de centre de décision en
France et par ailleurs elle surestime ce
que serait une contribution égalitaire à
1,75 je rappelle que Netflix enfin
pardon les plateformes audiovisuelles
ont une taxe de 5,15% important et que
ça n'a rien changé ça n'a pas eu
d'impact sur les prix etc et ça n'a pas
empêché la création française au
contraire alors qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ces plateformes qui disent
qu'il faudrait davantage d'accès les
gafams numérique et que c'est eux qui
devraient être minorités ils sont
puisque dans la contribution que je
propose il y a bien sûr également les
plateformes gratuites et donc ce serait
à peu près à part égale d'ailleurs la
contribution du gratuit et la
contribution du payant bien sûr ce que
je dis c'est que ça représenterait 15
centimes par abonnement franchement
c'est absorbable il y a eu aucune
conséquence lorsque nous avons mis en
place cette contribution pour les
plateformes audiovisuelles et lorsque
nous l'avons augmenté en 2020 à 5,15% et
que les décisions de prix etc sont pris
au niveau international européen sur
d'autres raisons ça permet de financer
ça leur apporterait c'est ça que je leur
réponds je leur réponds mais
engagez-vous dans une démarche qui va
permettre d'exporter vos artistes qui va
permettre aussi de financer une
politique publique qui
vous profite parce que au fond c'est ce
qui se passe dans le cinéma c'est à dire
la valve finance l'amont et tous les
canaux participent à la création ce
qu'on comprend dans votre propos et
j'espère que je suis correct mais ce
qu'il faut faire c'est en fait muscler
l'action de ce centre national de la
musique et en fait ça passe par un
financement propre c'est un peu ça en
fait la clé de voûte pour améliorer la
situation de la création musicale en
France c'est bien ça oui c'est ça ça
démontré sa robustesse pour le Centre
national du cinéma c'est-à-dire que on
fait contribuer les catalogues amortis
pour financer la création de demain donc
ça ça permettra de créer de financer les
rappeurs de demain mais la musique
classique aussi de demain les nouveaux
ensembles baroques français par exemple
qui marchent très bien mais qu'on peut
davantage aider avec effectivement
l'idée que tout le monde contribue à
part égale et sur un montant qui est
vraiment minime oui quelle est la
réception de la ministre de votre
proposition est-ce qu'on peut s'attendre
par exemple dans la prochaine loi de
finances qui arrivera à l'automne cette
taxe mis en place dans les cartons du
gouvernement c'est possible mais moi je
souhaite qu'est-ce qu'elle vous a dit la
ministre de la Culture moi je souhaite
elle a reçu le rapport elle écoute tous
les partenaires moi je souhaite que ça
puisse participer au débat sur les PLF
il est là pour ça ce rapport on a besoin
on a besoin d'une stratégie nouvelle
d'un d'un outil qui existe et qui
pourrait la porter et puis d'un
financement qui serait équitable et qui
finalement permettrait au Centre
national de la musique de marcher sur
deux pieds la musique enregistrée le
spectacle vivant et d'aider les deux et
je pense que c'est un cercle très
vertueux qui qui permet et aujourd'hui
en France on progresse mais on a encore
des marges de progression donc on pourra
tout à fait amortir ça et construire une
politique ambitieuse pour nos pour nos
isers nos industries culturelles pardon
merci Quentin
on va reparler bien sûr du sujet chaud
du moment ensemble dans le club et on va
parler la démission du maire de
Saint-Brévin avec vous on va parler
immigration aussi exactement le projet
de loi tant attendu
à suivre dans le club tout à l'heure
Quentin on va terminer en parlant de
politique et des sénatoriales c'est en
septembre que les sénatoriales ont lieu
le 24 septembre est-ce que vous êtes
candidat à votre succession Julien
barjoton Renaissance à investi les
sortants qui souhaitaient repartir c'est
mon cas je suis sortant j'ai fait un
seul montant et donc Renaissance a
réinvesti les sortants il y a bien sûr
des discussions dans la majorité
présidentielle au niveau national et
j'ai vocation à être le candidat de la
majorité présidentielle parce que
l'unité c'est notre talisman on y tient
comme à la prunelle de nos yeux l'unité
c'est le gage de l'efficacité si le la
majorité présidentielle par Unis elle
pourra espérer avoir quelques quelques
gains aussi notoriales je crois que
c'est dans l'intérêt de tout le monde on
va parler du National mais juste un mot
sur Paris la majorité présidentielle est
affaiblie à Paris est-ce que vous pensez
être en mesure de garder votre siège
vous avez une élection jamais ni perdu
ni gagner d'avance il faut y aller en
dynamique et avec un esprit collectif
c'est à dire rassembler au maximum les
personnes qui se retrouvent dans
l'action du Président de la République
et du gouvernement et qui ont une voix
apportée particulière de Paris sur la
culture parce que Paris c'est la culture
sur une écologie sérieuse et raisonnée
et sur le numérique les innovations
numériques mais également sur la
transformation des services publics
voilà les thèmes que je veux porter et
qui parle parisien parce qu'il faut se
nourrir de la société parisienne avec
agir avec le MoDem qui est plutôt avec
les républicains à Paris avec qui vous
allez rassembler il faut rassembler la
majorité présidentielle et là cette
majorité présidentielle elle se retrouve
évidemment pour être en conquête cet
esprit qu'est-ce que vous dites
dans la majorité la dernière fois mais
la dernière fois c'était le cas le la
numéro 2 sur la liste était modem
pourquoi est-ce que ce qui a été
possible en 2017 ne serait pas cette
fois en 2023 je ne le crois pas je pense
que cet esprit collectif qui doit
présider à notre avenir commun à Paris
l'emportera pour l'organisation la
préparation de ces sénatoriales en 2023
j'ai mon espoir et ensuite et bien il
faut faire campagne parce que vous
l'avez dit ça n'est ni gagné ni perdu
d'avance mais en tout cas on peut
l'inscrire dans une vision de conquête
pour pour Paris parce que derrière il y
a notamment les Européennes et on doit
faire un très gros score aux européennes
à Paris et sur le plan national vous
souhaitez une union d'horizon du MoDem
de Renaissance comme ça a été le cas au
législative bien sûr est-ce que là pour
le coup Horizon est en position de force
dans les négociations disposant de
plusieurs élus locaux mais la division
et la dispersion
sont les les garanties de perdre des
sièges personne n'y a intérêt s'il y a
ni division ni dispersion mais au
contraire une unité dans la dynamique
mais il va falloir donner des gages à
Édouard Philippe c'est pas une question
de gage à Edward Philippe c'est une
question d'être efficace nombre possible
le plus nombre possible au Sénat pour
soutenir le président de la République
son gouvernement et pour se retrouver
dans ce pôle central c'est ça qui est
important et donc il s'agit tout
simplement de dire de choisir les
meilleures candidats en fonction des
territoires mais y compris tout le monde
peut avoir des espoirs de gains que ce
soit horizon le modem Renaissance si
nous sommes unis je pense que cet esprit
de responsabilité qui a nous a
caractérisé jusque là et bien
l'emportera
il y a un groupe Renaissance auquel vous
appartenez les sénateurs horizons sont
dans un autre groupe est-ce qu'il faut
mais ça c'est de la majorité d'après ce
sont les sénateurs élus qui environ s'il
préfère faire un groupe etc il faut pas
décider il faut pas moi je suis pas pour
la verticalité comme ça si les sénateurs
qui sont élus dans cette esprit
collectif décide que c'est plus efficace
d'avoir plusieurs vies plus à plusieurs
groupes et si c'est un groupe unir un
groupe uni mais ça ça viendra après ce
qu'il faut d'abord c'est réussir ses
sénatoriales ensemble et on suivra bien
évidemment cette campagne dans cette
émission merci Julien bar je demande
d'être venu nous voir pendant cette
première demi-heure dans 20 minutes dans
le club on va donc reparler évidemment
de la démission du maire de Saint-Brevin
après des menaces et l'incendie de son
domicile personnel nos élus sont-ils
suffisamment protégés on se posera la
question mais d'abord on va attirer
notre prochaine invité c'est le général
Benoît Puga qui nous rejoint merci
Julien vergeton